alright let's take some calls 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 is the number we will start with
our first caller name and where you're
calling from hi David I am a Dakota
Coates previous caller great what's on
your mind um I was wondering what your
thoughts are on the the recent rise in
rape and hate crimes that are not hate
crimes but crimes that are happening in
countries that are taking in a bunch of
refugees and like my real question to
you is do you think that radical Islam
is making Europe crumble and like
destroying all of this like history
that's that's been there for so long you
see like places where you know there's
there's been amazing accomplishments in
science and in a literal literature and
all these places and there's people like
peeing and pooping in the in the street
right you know yeah well listen I mean
we've seen it we saw peeing and pooping
in the streets during during some
American protests as well I don't know
that I'd go by that unfortunately I mean
as horrific as that is no matter who's
doing the peeing or the pooping we don't
want to see it but that's not exactly
going to make a society crumble but I
think your question is a good one and
we've covered you know there are some
shows that will not really talk about
the issue that you're bringing up or
they'll talk about it in a way that for
me is just not being realistic or honest
enough I have no problem and we covered
at the end of at last New Year's Eve the
attacks that took place and and in many
of those attacks sexual assaults and
attempted rapes we were talking about an
immigrant population etc I think that we
need to take a thought akahl approach
here different countries have different
based on their populations and based on
the circumstances in their country they
have different capacities to take in
refugees they have different processes
for vetting who is a refugee that
deserves political asylum and and who is
not and and I think yeah to broadly say
Europe is crumbling because Muslims are
coming in that seems crazy to me to say
now it doesn't seem crazy to me to say
which I
that there are some on the left who will
say David how do you how do you say that
that it's perfectly fine to explore
whether there are incongruencies between
the cultures of individuals who come
into a country and the culture that's
there and it opens up a conversation
about assimilation and of course forced
assimilation is rarely something that
goes well these are complex issues and
the conversations need to be had ya know
I wanted to bring up a point because my
grandmother had just recently traveled
to Germany probably about a couple years
ago yeah and the family that she was
staying with they weren't too like these
have been these are like you know tenth
generation German people that have been
there and they didn't like the Germans
just because they are the Muslims
because they wouldn't assimilate into
the culture and you know Angela Merkel
is living in like 6 million of these
people a year you know it's like you
you're you're really kind of
disregarding what the the national
population one
yeah well listen I mean you were now
getting into very specific anecdotes
about one family that I've never met
that someone told you claims they don't
like so I don't know that I have much of
a comment on that but needless to say I
think this is a real issue that deserves
conversation and exploration and it can
be explored in a way that is not
offensive nor quote Islamophobic and I
think that's really the key we can talk
about these issues while still being
sensitive to the fact that we're talking
about in refugees people who are by and
large in really horrible situations
where they've left in many cases the
only country they've known thank you so
much for the call I really appreciate it
all right real problem you